[Music]
[Music]
oh hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what's up
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
bad boys
[Music]
it seems i'm unfashionably late
but i'm ready to give you everything you
want
[Music]
break
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this stage is set for chocobo's next big
victory
chocobo gp
the winner will be granted one wish
anything they want
news of this race is bringing all the
familiar faces back together
there's only one requirement to enter
your ride must have wheels
put the pedal to the metal master
drifting to zoom around the track
use magicite to take down your rivals
and powerful abilities to turn the
tables
[Music]
meet and compete with new friends and
make a dash for the finish line
chocobo gp
coming 2022
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah hello
[Music]
you are faced with overwhelming power
your highest priority it should be
simply to survive
so
there may be a very small opportunity to
escape
don't let your guard down
samus aaron the most powerful bounty
hunter in the galaxy embarks on a new
mission to the uncharted planet zdr
for objectives
confirm whether the deadly x parasite
still exists and figure out why the emmy
research robots in search of it have
mysteriously gone dark
early readings reveal that planet zdr is
divided into multiple environments
each with its own elements
and organisms
remnants of the mighty chozo
civilization are also scattered
throughout including evidence that the
chozo may have once called the planet
their home
visit
metroid.nintendo.com to read metroid
dread report volume 8 for a detailed
account of the terrain and life forms
you may encounter in the metroid dread
game
be sure to view the other metroid dread
reports there as well
you'll want to prepare yourself for the
dangers that lie ahead
metroid dread launches on nintendo
switch october 8th pre-orders are
available now on nintendo eshop
do you hear that
it's the most pathetic applause in the
world harry made of pity
[Music]
time to fire up the old lye machine
a touch of absurdity there
nice
[Applause]
is this some kind of joke good things
can still happen
what's wrong with you
you mean someone stole your badge
i'm not a real police officer
what are you doing
[Music]
if you could only find your gun
[Applause]
[Music]
disco elysium the final cut
[Music]
embrace the reassurance of physical
media